[Música]
apenas dos años después de que yo bailé
en llegar a la casa blanca la temporada
electoral está de vuelta el presidente
de eeuu inicia su campaña de mitad de
período en el campo de batalla político
de pensilvania tema clave en su agenda
hacer frente a la violencia armada estoy
decidido a prohibir las armas de asalto
en este país decidido
[Aplausos]
ya lo hice una vez y lo volveré a ser
torque
bardem pido al congreso que apruebe una
prohibición de las armas de asalto este
verano pero para que esto ocurra los
demócratas tendrán que reforzar su
control sobre la cámara de
representantes y el senado en las
elecciones de noviembre eso será un gran
desafío teniendo en cuenta el bajo
índice de aprobación de bailén que ha
estado por debajo del 50% durante más de
un año en medio de un aumento de la
violencia con armas de fuego en eeuu
bailén también ha prometido formar y
financiar a 100.000 agentes de policía
adicionales contradiciendo el mensaje de
algunas de las voces más liberales de su
partido
cuando se trata de la seguridad pública
en esta nación la respuesta no es
desfinanciar a la policía es financiar a
la policía financiar a la policía pero
los republicanos reprochan al presidente
por evitar los temas que según ellos son
los más importantes para los
estadounidenses desde la inflación hasta
la inmigración la visita del presidente
a weeks barry fue la primera de tres
apariciones en pensilvania durante la
próxima semana mientras tanto el ex
presidente de donald trump tiene
previsto visitar la misma ciudad el
sábado